الان الى تطورات الميدانيه لحرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وقالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
انها اسقطت 10 مسيرات في هجوم روسي الليله
الماضيه على جنوب شرقي البلاد وقالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها صدت 17 هجوما
اوكرانيا في محور دونتسك نلخص التطورات
الميدانيه مع مراسليله من كراماتوست مازن
ابراهيم ومن دونه امين درغامي وابدا مع
مازن ابراهيم وما يقوله الاوكرانيون عن
سير المعارك الاساسيه في ظل حديث الروس عن
استخدام الاوكرانيين قذائف في خيرسن لا
يعرفون كنها كذلك حارقه لا يعرفون ما هي
في الواقع زين العابدين يمكن الحديث اليوم
عن تفاوت في حده المعارك بين منطقه واخرى
على طول هذه الجبهه ولا يمكن الحديث عن
نسق متكامل يمتد من وصولا الى خرسون وما
بينهما عمليا هنالك متغيرات بمعنى ان حجم
المعارك تراجع نسبيا في بعض المناطق
واحتدم في مناطق اخرى ولكن القاسم المشترك
بين كل المناطق وفق قياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه عمليات قصف روسيا استهدفت
مجموعه كبيره من المدن والمناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه والمتاخمه
لخط الجبهه تحديدا في المقاطعات الشرقيه
من خاركاز مرورا
الحديث هنا من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه عن
استهداف
لكوبيانسك لليمان لمحيط باخموت
مارينكا هذه المناطق تقول قياده
الاوكرانيه بانها تمكنت في كل تلك المناطق
من صد محاوله التقدم الروسيه والتي
استخدمت فيها مختلف انواع الاسلحه
وبالتالي الحديث الاوكراني هنا ليس عن
تقدم او هجوم مضاد ولكن عن صد هجمات
نفذتها القوات الروسيه ضمن هذه المحاور
اما على مستوى
فالحديث مختلف بالنسبه لقياده الاركان
الاوكرانيه احد كبار القاده العسكريين
الاوكران تحدث عن تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه
ولكنه التقدم بسيط تحدث عن نحو 1700 متر
مربع في
اتجاهولوجيا وبالتالي هو يقول بان ضمن هذه
المنطقه حققت القوات الاوكرانيه تقدما
ولكن بطبيعه الحال هو تقدم محدود ايضا كان
لافته الحديث عن المسيرات التي تم اسقاطها
خلال الساعات الاربعه والعشرين ماضيه من
قبل القوات الاوكرانيه والتي اشارت الى
انها كانت كان هنالك مجموعه من الطائرات
الانتحاريه التي حاولت ان تنفذ ه طالت
مختلف المناطق مناطق جنوب شرق اوكرانيا
يضاف الى كل ذلك الحديث الجديد اليوم على
ان هنالك محاوله من القوات الروسيه لاعاده
موضوعها في الضفه الشرقيه لنهر دينيبر
بعدما كانت قد انسحبت من تلك المنطقه في
اعقاب تفجير سكه فلنتابع الحديث الذي قالت
عنه وتحدثت به الناطقه باسم القوات
الجنوبيه الاوكرانيه والتي اشارت الى هذا
الامر معطوفا عليه حديثها عن تواجد سفن
حربيه روسيه في البحر الاسود وهي تشكل
خطرا لاطلاق صواريخ باتجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
سفينه حربيه روسيه في البحر الاسود منها
سفينه وغواصه مجهزتان ب 12 صاروخا من نوع
كاليبر قادره على اصابه اي هدف في عموم
اوكرانيا لذلك يبقى خطر الاستهداف
الصاروخي قائما كما تستمر القوات الروسيه
بمحاولات العوده الى مواقعها التي تركتها
سابقا في منطقه ضفه نهر دنيفر وتسعى الى
فرض سيطرتها على تلك المنطقه لكن قواتنا
تصد كافه محاولاتهم
نشكر مازن ابراهيم من سلوف يانس ونتحول
الى امين درغامي في دوناتسكو حديث ايضا
روسي عن تقدم في شمال ضخمه بجانب ما
ذكرناه من
القذائف غير المعروفه في خيرسن التفاصيل
معك امين
العابدين يمكن تقسيم الجبهه اليوم بحسب
المعطيات الى نوعين نوع تقوم فيه القوات
الروسيه بالدفاع عن بعض نقاطها او نقاط
تمركوزها ايضا على بعض المواقع المحصنه
التي تمكنت من تامينها خلال السيطرتها
عليها في الاونه الاخيره
وجبهات اخرى ومحاور اخرى
تهاجم فيها القوات الروسيه على الاقل هذا
ما يصلنا بحسب مواقع عسكريه روسيه من
مختلف الجبهات تؤكد على ان جيش الروسي نشط
من عملياته العسكريه خاصه في محاور
كوبيانسك في مقاطعه خاركيز وايضا في محور
كراس نيليمان وفي بخموت طبعا الحديث عن ان
القوات الروسيه السيطره على مناطق
استراتيجيه في شمال مدينه باخموت امس
وايضا توغلها في داخل الجبهه الاوكرانيه
بناها الجيش الاوكراني عام 2014 والحديث
هنا عن ذلك الخط الدفاعي الذي كان يطلق
عليه خط وقف اطلاق النار بين جانبين في
جنوب دنيات ولكن المصادر العسكريه تؤكد
على ان الجيش الاوكراني شنه هجوما مضادا
واسترجع تلك المواقع من الجيش الروسي
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم
ثاني يوم على التوالي تستثني الحديث عن
قيام الجيش الاوكراني بشن هجمات في
زبروجيا المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع قال
بان القواته صدت 17 هجوما في دونيات بما
فيها طبعا
هجمات في كراس نيليمان هجمات في كوبيانسك
وايضا في بعض المناطق في خرسول لكنه لم
يشير الى اي هجمات في زاباروجيا وهذا
لربما ما يفسر تراجع حده الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد في محور زابروج فلن ستمع الى ما
قاله المتحدث باسم الوزاره حول هذه
الهجمات التي قال بان القوات الروسيه قد
صدتها
شنت القوات الاوكرانيه محاولات هجوم في
محاور دونيسك وكراس
في محور
17 هجوما للعدو بنجاح في بلدات
بلغت خسائر العدو في هذا المحور 315
عسكريا قتيلا وتم تدمير مدرعتين وثلاث
شاحنات صغيره ومدافع كما تم تدمير
مستودعين للذخيره لوائين للدفاع الاقليمي
في منطقتي
من